hey hi hello hi welcome back
last week we what do we do just an hour
ago party and then that birthday party
and things yep
and I feel like I did pretty good like
I'm actually very impressed that I
didn't die and I almost killed myself by
hitting a tripwire bomber and I
accidentally used a health that was my
two biggest errors but if you don't
include my errors I feel like I'm doing
okay so oh is this happy birthday the
video I've already watched yep that was
doing that just making sure you burned
alive in okay so including all that
let's just talk about what I'm about to
do so I just finished that and he's mad
at me
and I didn't die and I got I got this
baby
nope I got this baby and now at this
point I'm loading up my stuff in saving
assuming that there's either gonna be
another puzzle or perhaps a larger this
way a little more
you saw Zoe on the camera saying that
her and Mia were locked up on the pier
and I want to save them okay so you have
the d-series head and arm right can you
compete right now
I don't know I that's not a thing I know
where's the arm yep I can look at it but
it doesn't look like I can come by now
who doesn't give me the option to
combine it so no no okay okay so just
you know this is your time to do the
training thing so where am I at with I
got a gun I got a shotgun and I got a
grenade launcher I've got two grenades
for whatever ammo you can I've got four
herbs I've got one handgun ammo that's
not very good
I got a chem fluid so I could make more
but I think I should make a health with
that personal
I don't think I have any other ammo oh I
got shotgun shells let's see you can
probably bring that strong chem fluid
sure and maybe the supplements in case
you get some stuff to combine it with
some supplements yeah you technically
could make rounds with it okay should I
take just one yeah so here's where I'm
at I would like to make a health cuz I'm
on yellow and I feel like I'm gonna need
it okay cool
and now I'm gonna save I can't do any
more new saves cuz apparently have run
out yes
I wish I would have you know what we
left in between the last two videos to
get water and I I didn't get water I'm
drinking the same coffee which is now
not cold it's like lukewarm so anyway
that's that room and I think I can leave
right yeah okay well let's do it oh I
don't like the way these are organized
sorry
well it's fine I guess I like to put
this here because I'm less likely to hit
up okay which means I'm less likely to
accidentally use it does that make sense
it's a legitimate concern considering
how often I accidentally waste things
you sneaky devil I think I have to do
this because I can't jump I could try
did you see what I just did I almost
created it that would have been fine if
what if you grenade it and bottle it I
would have been I would have restarted
the safe cool
okay that's it
do you think I brought enough bullets
just keeps crowding
I feel like I didn't bring enough
bullets can I just look real fast I only
have 18 bullets 11 shotgun shells and
some grenade launcher stuff I don't feel
like it's a lot oh I need the crank say
bucks are you serious
sorry Grammy whatever I hope my hands
are in a controller in one crank
I was always wondering if I was gonna
ever use that again now I know
so should I put the crank away yeah I
think so
save that slot sorry it's too close to
Christmas break I'm no longer able to
concentrate Sam
I feel like on Christmas break work
productivity must go down so bad yeah
but I start to take calls and emails and
like what do you call that like I I'm
not going into the office but I'm from
home I'm doing stuff in remotely I'm
working room I'm like kind of working
remotely I have to get stuff done but on
my own time I slept in until 11:00 today
but I still had to do stuff does that
make sense it took lots of calls I'm
like hey call me jet okay I'm gonna go
this one looks like it doesn't go
anymore so I'm gonna go to get those
shells oh I thought that was a shell I
want to show you a gun show yeah look
hold on looks like a box of shotgun
shells see uh yeah kind of definitely
does are there any more trip wires I
think you're out of the trip wire
section okay good because I hate that
because I have to go so slowly what
about the mean box section I think
I hear a bobblehead oh there you are you
little how is he bobbing on back
it's not a bobbles work okay so now I
have another chem fluid which means I
could make more bullets but you want me
to wait right mm-hmm okay
I'm doing I'm actually in pretty good
shape now I have 43 bullets that's a lot
that's great yeah they give you a [ __ ]
ton of bullets I wonder what's gonna
happen oh right how many coins do you
have I don't remember I have maybe a
couple I put the [ __ ] crank away damn
it
[ __ ] that happened really fast
it all happened so fast [ __ ] that thing
really got me geez
all right see you right here I'm going
to fight that [ __ ] again why did
that go so badly for me come on that
went better killing it
wait I had that he's not that he's not
that I'm just kidding
he has no head oh that eight they are
procedural they are and I don't want
that better before boy that's enough
burner fuel for me to separate it yeah
don't me to do that sure okay it's gonna
cost me a separating agent but it's
worth it I think
don't make Renee's out yeah I agree it's
that noise oh god oh my god it just
could have been avoided if you said to
bring the train for us yeah I go green
[ __ ] nice quick turn
Kalinin why is the music still scary
they need to finish their resolve their
melody oh my god Ron you [ __ ] why are
there so many i need more firepower oh
you're gonna be left
dai please please be dead [ __ ] off
oh yeah there you go
the music is still scary I used all of
my new bullets this is some [ __ ]
alright you got it
for a [ __ ] crank
unbelievable
we've learned a valuable lesson take the
crank oh god I'm scared sorry should I
save again I don't want to do that okay
so here's what we can do we can combine
this 80 burner fuel with that 50 right
yeah get separate that okay now I need
to get the separating agent which is
blue got it and bring that strong I'm
fluid when you're done with okay so come
bin with that and I will get a chem
fluid is that what we want to do yeah
okay just make sure that that's what we
want yeah okay I get rid of those burn
that burner fuel you got it all right
okay
you don't need those yeah you actually
keep those for in case I want to make
more grenades go to the combine screen
quick well just go go oh no sorry okay I
see where it's I see what the combined
screen you don't have oh you can make oh
so narrow rounds supplements and strong
chem fluid will make that stuff I guess
whatever that is probably worth it
knowing
yeah keep it keep it now don't don't
don't combine yes well I'm out of
bullets for naught
you got a bunch dude get some get some
gunpowder out you have six gunpowder's
and can't lose okay so I'll get some
gunpowder do you think that's worth it
no no no so should I not do this I'm so
confused I have three chem fluid cz's
yeah but you don't need a handgun Oh mom
you don't want me to make handgun ammo
but I can make shotgun ammo no you can't
why not I don't think you can make
shotgun shells can you know oh I didn't
know that damn it
I'm saving just say that's the supplies
right now sorry I feel very strongly
that I should save that scene went
fairly well yeah I wonder I want to go
to avoided waste on that I'm oh if we
brought the crank who knows history is
not on our side right now yeah alright
so I'm running out of stuff you're
telling me to take all this [ __ ] just to
be bring the strong chem fluid I have
one yeah bring it bring me the other one
just bring one more strong chemical
you'll be alright with all this stuff
here we go
I can't believe was that was that what
that was that was a punishment
why is this music scary just avoid them
possible honestly are they behind you oh
wait what was that behind you
stop no no up that was a lie
I don't think you know what I think oh
my god there are two of them we're good
stop Jesus I have to go this way why
because I have to raise the crank [ __ ]
Mike I can't imagine you being more or
less helpful you almost said that
correctly do it like it was gonna happen
anyway because you're gonna raise the
bridge then you go back and you get hurt
that this was gonna happen whether
whether or not I brought the crank this
was it's good to know this was my life
now we don't feel [ __ ] because you did
handle them well actually got hit no you
didn't get hit at all the second time
around
uh yeah yeah this music is it's because
I'm in this area it's not like res knee
before where just thought you know five
or when it stops
let me through
yeah [ __ ] you stop coming out of the
[ __ ] woodwork literally lemme in oh
we got a flame back so that changes what
I was mentioning about that
exploding Jesus oh you could separate
that if you uh you don't have them
separated ooh you're getting a lot of
share right now this should scare you
yeah oh I'm full don't need the crank
now I'm like uh-huh 80% uh-huh so you
got health I've one health it's probably
not enough but I can make more here's my
suggestion okay
make neural rounds with these
supplements and the strong chem fluid
again yeah you'll still have one strong
can fluid left over save that so you're
saying this yeah done and now make I
can't do that you probably make another
health I would say just say it more than
one so you don't worry about eating
herbs and which barely do anything to
begin with done
sweet the rest is just like should I
keep this stuff like I don't need this
burner fuel unless I'm gonna bring the
burner you don't have any more
separating agents I might no I'm gonna
take this off them cuz I can't use it
yeah unless this is the kind of bad guy
where it would be good to have
I recommend you don't bring I'm sorry
I'm saving so much but I just don't want
to this is the thing like if you're not
gonna punish me for saving as much as I
want I'm gonna save as much as I want
mm-hmm like this game is not punishing
in that way so I'm gonna take it to my
advantage
all right so oh I have no bullets for
this gun which means there's no
reasonable search in this room I don't
think you finished search there's an
Arab over on that chair I see I see
shotgun shells so much but like I don't
need this I wonder do you want to go
upstairs I don't know like I'm not gonna
bring this gun um you know what I mean I
mean I honestly would keep it cause like
you can't put anything else besides
weapons in those equippable spots
you wouldn't it's not taking up space
technically right okay and if you need
to on the fly you have the supplies for
handgun ammo but I wouldn't use it yet
okay all right so okay here we go
are you ready okay
I've loved this music saver music it
really calms me not in a creepy way it
just actually comes Traverse Town level
of original Resident Evil level of save
room I don't like the idea that a boss
is coming
oh god yeah yeah you [ __ ] this is your
fault can I help them come on how do I
help them use bear sex on her okay wait
make sure she's not [ __ ] amazing you
fell right into my Corral
stop I thought that was in the game
sounds like dude from hell blade Zoe Zoe
right now we don't have the time do you
have both ingredients nice hair for
poops it's not on me
anticlimactic oh wait can you search
this room first why you know you it's
not gonna trigger anything no yeah okay
nevermind sorry sorry ladies I didn't
know I didn't know
damnit here I come to save the day
no worries ladies I am Jim and Andy yet
on Netflix no it's really good
documentary about Jim Carrey's method
acting with man on the moon oh I heard
about you give me the seconds okay here
you get here there should be enough
right wrist on accident well he's coming
daddy's coming good me I just say that
yeah the my girlfriend or whatever said
it there's enough it's been through a
lot to make the serum what's next well
take it through the swamp okay gimme hey
what are those is man
Oh what the [ __ ] is that what is it is
that the dad baby oh my god [ __ ] him up
eyes Oh dodge oh you should have said
that earlier or what sorry
fine you got a check points but I'm so
dumb I was truly that prepared now why I
was like in the house in the molded I
was in the menu trying to heal I'm dumb
this is really good
Stumptown coffee good that wasn't scary
but it was definitely weird like I
didn't scream like I did earlier you
know yeah I was such a bummer
damnit
like how did I not dodge to be honest
with you
nice nothing what do I do now
oh it's like two shots I would do well
up oh no I'm in the water
what's going on should I go back up yeah
sure it's up to you you don't have to
like if you can see some eyes and make a
plan I can't he'll kill his wife
what oh yeah yeah I miss how you got it
I did
ha he's hungry today Evo's retching the
right should I use the other ammo guys
now you're doing pretty well I mean so
the grenades are drugs you know if the
aim as precisely adult the explosion I
need to heal and I don't have any
feeling yeah you still [ __ ] up though
this this what this fight is a so you
had the right idea at first like I
should have any more heels no no no see
in order to dodge
you don't go side to side like if he's
gonna swing drop down to the water and
then when he comes down try to climb
back up it's about like changing planes
like what you're just saying I need to
dodge like I mean like the ladders
there's also a boxes there are boxes
down it felt like I couldn't judge yeah
you got a drop down or climb up cuz he
swings laterally but also there are
boxes down there I think one of them has
damn I really thought I had at that time
yeah you're pretty accurate I think
there is kombucha downstairs like what
do I do
I drop down right now if you can where I
just there's nowhere to go
no staff here now just wait until he
comes on to your level I'm not impressed
this is good old Jack
[ __ ] I forgot he's gonna hit me thank
you
try I don't know where to go try
climbing alright while you're here you
get that locks gonna press left for the
night yeah
let me help ya well was it as either
health or burner field hopefully
deployment [ __ ] knees up there shot
shooting then drop oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
got a lot of weight why did I make that
noise I need to stagger you you're drunk
jack tonight Oh Lord
[Music]
the weird fight yeah yeah climb up there
[ __ ] shoot from from the buzz okay
it's just a weird fight because I feel
like I can't get hurt very much I'm
haven't been getting hurt this time like
is you actually he's staggering he but
he's not hurting you it's like one thing
that he does like [ __ ] me up like I
can't get hit with him by him more than
like a couple times
[ __ ] you probably get one shot and then
drop I don't know where behind you oh
yeah you just dies that gunpowder yeah
should I go back down or up yeah I don't
know where the hell is it right behind
you right I am sure you're very scary
let's go got the shot oh that's alright
you got it you're good
should I yield yeah oh right there on
the shelf there's something there I see
it's two things
yeah health and shotgun shells got like
two more eyes I think Scott [ __ ] ton of
eyes what should I go I'm falling
Allen's stomach while you're down yeah
that one that one's step one with that
stuff yeah a nice that was the hardest
one okay where's the last his but I
think the glass was the top of this town
Yeah right there oh I'm sorry you might
have to reload reload my gun nope yeah
all right bottom line crap all your wood
nice dodge right next to you yeah let
everything kick in
I sorry I'm afraid to get hurt something
like really paranoid
I think it sounded stomach so let him
come up here completely
gonna hit me like now drop down that was
bad advice well where is it all right
there
now that was fired that's it hey you got
it
same thing oh yeah yeah oh one more all
right no might not I got the first one
yeah get behind him yeah break his box
wake him he's flailing
what should I hurt him yeah I'll reload
your hand got any case you need it I'm
pretty sure you're on empty on your
handgun okay
yeah grenade launcher where am I going I
can't oh just don't kill yourself yeah
[ __ ] you jack one more nope alright
you're good you're alive you're alive
I don't have any healed all right
there's boxes near you if you wanna back
out yeah yeah yeah yeah nice job oh you
got him the fire the fire got him nice
you'd actually did not use as much ammo
as you could've that was good
can I get around him cuz there's boxes
past his way I'm pretty sure they the
ones you just picked up they push I
think come on don't Resident Evil 6 me I
killed you was there an option there
now there's only one serum one
we're boss fight but I actually really
do like
what's he looking at hey yeah check for
items did you yeah there you go I knew
it
what if that was explosively rigged shy
quick I would have survived maybe is
that it I think so but maybe
double-check yeah I can't get to it if
it's passed there so I actually don't
want to know
cool so one boss fight down and I didn't
use a lot of these grenade launchers
which is nice but I don't have enough
serum for these ladies I had to use one
of them there's only one left
there's the only one left there can't
just be one left the hell are we gonna
do now you're the one who told me to use
it dum-dum
Oh Oh does this change the game leader
would you rather save well probably my
girlfriend I guess that's what I did
it's up to you though like who Zoey
she's one who helped me she's been
helping you she's part of the Baker
family but she's like not fully turned
yet like the other ones are and Lucas
also likes the power me as your
girlfriend he haven't seen for two years
I probably should cure my girlfriend
it's what most people do it I'll say
that but there's no like well I'll tell
you it's not like Mass Effect levels of
choice like it's you're not gonna like
you're not gonna beat resonable seven
and then look back and be like I wonder
what would happen if I mean you might
but it's not gonna be again it's not
gonna be a totally different game
depending on who's safe okay well if
you're not gonna stop me I in like if I
was by myself I would probably cure my
girlfriend
that's just how I swim okay do you want
to see what happens if I cure the other
person no I know what happens the first
time I played I cured Mia okay Zoey go
you just go come with us I'm sure
there's someone who can help this is not
home
apparently I belong yeah I'm gonna fight
her later I bet I'll send help
don't bother there won't be anyone left
to help oh I feel bad
well good luck this isn't sorry sorry
okay so that's equal seven shut up that
was the game I'd very surprised cuz I
even killed the brother yet
I feel bad even thank you
how else was I gonna choose
Mia was that mean you're a lot we need
to talk maybe it was just Kurt yeah
that's something to do with all of us
didn't you
look I just want to know the truth
Ethan I honestly don't remember try
is that the book [ __ ] it back in here
what boat
what boat
why is there a boat you're okay
the hell was that Gators oh my god I
don't know what that was didn't really
get a good look at it but it had
tentacles sort of molded
oh I'm her I'm Mia and if I chose the
other girl I would have played as her
that's interesting I wonder if I would
go through the exact same level I assume
so
right okay I have no I got nothing oh I
have a bottle actually Oh
e:00 one okay
Oh gross
Oh
[Music]
my boyfriend
so that was my yes my Biff is dead and
now I'm a lady trying to escape
interesting I think he's still alive is
an interesting change
this looks important
I mean it might not be but
god I have no way to defend myself
so there's just like a ship I'm in a
ship with a bunch of values do you ever
have to do that when you were younger
what you hold your tongue and you say
I'm on a ship with a bunch of apples
hold your tongue huh like that yeah
supposed to make you say I'm on a ship
with a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of
Apple yeah I thought you meant like your
teachers how'd you do it
no that would be inappropriate what's
going on is this a back flashback maybe
so
sorry they when he said like that
there's the ship why is it here what
ship was I supposed to know wondering if
you're supposed to know what it is yet
yeah no it's just that was just like a
background thing you'll figure out okay
I just don't know what the ship is and
it's significant you're not I don't
there's like minor allusions to it
but it's not something you should be
expected to really know okay
Oh Oh God ichael it see that are molded
and I can't fight a molded right now I
don't have anything they wouldn't throw
them all today you and you have no
inventory
oh yeah those are people oh that's my
cousin Donny that's Benny that's Hana
Jackie get it Benihana Benny and Hana
was Benny Hana originally Benny Hannah
and then they got like a divorce and he
was like [ __ ] yeah yeah Hana
people liked my Portland story
Oh mr. T or whatever yeah yeah thanks to
okay I still have no items they go in
there she killed them all and I don't
know what that is take it you might need
it you never know when whiteboards spray
will come in handy if you had a lighter
you could use as a flamethrower I think
actually I don't know if the whiteboard
sprays flammable
I was kind of hoping for a bubblehead I
wonder who killed them all who is she
if it's my girlfriend I'm gonna be very
upset because I saved her instead of
that other lady who was nice it's not
your girlfriend anymore it's you oh
right
if it's me I'm gonna be upset oh it's
pretty far and it saved oh [ __ ]
okay good actually like dead ends
because then I can cross it off of my
where to go next and I came from there
okay
oof I got anxiety this where he started
I'm so confused she's not my child
oh god that's [ __ ] gross Edie
Charlie paul Fitzgerald Giovanni
fanchetti Clarke Walsh Diane Charles Jim
Stockman Gerald Waddell but there's no
woman's name on there so it doesn't
really tell me very much
Jim Jim Waddell you can open that I
think I can okay damn I wish you had
done that before you knew well how did
he die a bunch of kids stuffed it in the
locker with shaving cream after an
atomic wedgie claims four kids every
year it's very rare
I used to have a little brother we died
via swirly third-grade speed of kids and
getting bullied
I met dude who played Dustin I saw your
photo how cool his real name he seems
like a nice guy
yeah he seemed kind of annoyed which I
would be too but everybody I was asking
for photos ah I think I think it must be
very hard I saw a hole Oh God I saw a
hole twitter discussion about how I
think one of them got yelled at online
for not like saying no thank you to a
photo and a person was like [ __ ] you oh
I would be if I was like if I was in
their position I wouldn't I would always
be and he know yeah I live my life and
he was like you need to respect the fact
that we're children and I thought that
was very mature of him but he's right
it's like like leave them alone they're
just they're just kids
I mean they're so young I mean imagine
being famous like that so young must be
like really crazy they're gonna be
messed up when they're older I hope not
that's why I said it was like how do you
know to be how does it feel to know
you're gonna be I would I'm kidding I
messed up I wasn't a child celebrity I'm
still not gonna be
an old nobody like me welcome to the
club I feel like I'm gonna get a
flashback in here cuz this looks like a
living room
oh tanker Annabelle built in 1987 71
thousand tonnage and 948 feet good to
know what that's 142 thousand pounds no
yeah no no no wow wow wow
1 million 420 Oh were you multiplying
seventy one thousand times 2 thousand 1
million four hundred twenty thousand I
think I mean if not like 40 million math
room I'm gonna do it I think it's 14
million two hundred forty fourteen
million two hundred thousand is my guess
look at that angel I know I'm not
beating that guy with a stick hearing
intelligent no he's not my forte
that's why calculators exist Oh Lord
sorry people who already figured it out
okay 142 million oh it's me it's me uh
oh nice I get what you were trying to do
there so I'm like a devil child or
something I [ __ ] this place up god
dammit Mia I wonder if I picked the
other girl if she would have lived like
the whole time cuz it sounds like me is
not a good person sorry I'm always like
a grass is greener person I have that
problem all the time like where I order
something I'm like I should have ordered
the other thing yeah I know
so like giving me a choice between my
girlfriend in that lady I feel like
you're supposed to choose that lady and
they knew you'd pick your girlfriend
because you're closer to her and then
that's like oh I didn't even look at
that guy out gee now I still haven't
found any items
all right whatever so I
what are you talking about wait
she's such a creep
where did I come from I came from those
stairs should I not go in here like
should I try to go follow her can that
molded stuff covered up the door gun
what did I get I got some chem fluid in
one of them yeah well now you're getting
items that's not good
like if as long as I don't get items
that means that I can't fight anything
shut the [ __ ] up I can't hurt this thing
are you sure it's a law
oh [ __ ] no this door yeah holy [ __ ] this
sucks
shelf nice how do I open it nice there
you go yeah that'll keep me alive
I'm not gonna make anything yet
I can't I can't even open this so keep
exploring no there's a guy out there
nice knife this is some [ __ ]
he's probably out there go find out
Oh God
that's him so so go that way
stairs or a door either one well he's
not in hearing more right because I let
him out
hopefully Oh sounds like he's in here oh
okay that's all you're right nope what
is it that stairs goes back home oh my
[ __ ] guy go around him no no the
ground one's gonna be harder about where
am I going to get right you haven't come
here oh okay got it
[ __ ] Oh or back to the door she went
through the girl you got a fuse yeah
going so you can I'm pretty sure this
fuse can open that going now oh there's
something you didn't check to the right
no no you work that's where you got it
no yeah dad I haven't been in here
did he come in I [ __ ] don't have a
knife give me a knife
something to read can I know you'll come
back here okay I need a knife you need a
gun but I can't open up anything there's
not gonna be a gun in a box so you got a
fuse you can go through the door that
the girl went through now right okay
it's just a matter of dodging dudes
until you get there [ __ ] there's so many
and I don't even know where I am you're
on the exact opposite corner of the door
that you need to go through so I don't
know where I am
so take you can go through this door if
you want to but you're going to the door
at the far end of that Hall oh I'll go
in there that dead guy might have a gun
I'm not promising I don't know I'm just
saying he might yeah your logical please
yes two different ones I go oh and I can
save that seems worth it's like a
Russian gun you got two bullets cool
you could save and call it an episode no
let's go using fuse we have a little bit
I don't think it's been an hour almost
but we started at 5 but let's let's go
see let's do that door ok I will I
strongly advise against using the ammo
if you can help it ok because you have 2
rounds I don't you think that's good
yeah I don't I don't think it would but
it could stagger them so I could get
around them and not get hurt again
you should just dodge him all right I'll
just dodge ok please don't
the left side of door please let me in
yeah
shut it thank you wait wait look at that
so you're I'm in the laundry room no I
know but like a look at the map itself
just there's five floors oh wow
so there's a lot like this area is not
small okay I understand that
it's merge me the tanker from Sons of
Liberty so weird cuz I really thought I
was gonna spend it all in that house
okay so I should probably do it floor by
floor right okay yeah cuz yeah you still
gonna have a good way to break those
crates yet yeah you're right so I'm
gonna come back okay
no lights are on at least that's nice
what is the third floor where's the map
say oh like what floor it is through
quarters maybe sick bed I'll control
room in sickbay why is this sickbay
right next to the control room yeah that
seems like poor planning I mean
obviously something went wrong here
anyway so it doesn't matter but maybe
that's what rent went wrong oh god this
is so the ring hey watch it
what why you need to remember so we can
be a family
[ __ ] creep you're a creep kid
she's like the grandma you're sitting
there staring you yeah and I can't point
my gun at her see
this games taking a turn oh that's what
the vial said that you picked up the
beginning or you hang on 0:01 is your
name it's not left oh yeah
well I've come to terms with that child
being me I guess it's over v 2014 I was
right around when shadow of mordor came
out that is a weird thing to remember
day before my brother's birthday day
before Weathertop attack happened in
Lord of the Rings
fellowship the ring Fellowship of the
Rings did not happen in 2014 the date
October 6 was when the ring wraiths
attacked the hobbits on by the top
October 6th whatever Third Age you're
getting worse as you must have infected
me during the attack who's Alan to [ __ ]
on anyway
don't know yet but it serves me right
it's my fault she got out yeah it is
your fault but that doesn't mean I'm
gonna let you die she didn't attack you
it's the front of her imprinting
protocol I can't believe this is
happening
imprinting protocol it it has her tissue
samples
you find her fix this okay Evie where
are you Evie so it's not me I'm very
confused machine gun ammo yeah okay
director Alan droney and caretaker Mir
winters recent reports suggest that if
Evelyn remains at her current location
she's at high risk of being stolen by
opposing organizations your orders
therefore are to transfer Evelyn to our
Central American branch for safekeeping
until further notice now it's getting to
like Resident Evil status like umbrellas
involved as in they aren't they during
transfer be sure to adhere to the
following protocols act as a parental
guideline for Evaline at all times
got it guardians forever line at all
times manage Evelyn's vitals if the
mission is compromised to dispose of
Evelyn geez okay remember that name
Evelyn yeah so Evie is the nickname for
Evelyn got it remember Evelyn was
mentioned a few times in the house or
photos of her when she was young
look at this I have a knife it's a
submachine gun - and remember when Lucas
was talking to you on the VHS
he's like Evelyn I'm I'm trying to kill
him or whatever he looked off camera -
the Evelyn yes times it might I mean
like a few more minutes might be a good
time to stop okay well we could stop now
actually it on a cliffhanger target oh
it tells me how close she is
I just want to see her yikes yikes why
am i collecting items so this is in the
past because the game takes place in
2017 so this is 2014 so technically if
you collect items like you could assume
that maybe if you put them in boxes
they'll still be there in the president
I honestly don't even remember if that's
true but that's what I would think this
game has been really good about like
having the past I have no idea where I
am
I'm just looking in places oh it's a Kim
there's a poll mama uh what's that
is that it box Horde sweetie sweetie
she's vomiting damn well I have to reset
I know what that means
how's it going she's vomiting far more
in excess of her body mass so her vomit
is where those monsters come from isn't
it
so now what
Oh for [ __ ] sake
I didn't know what that was submachine
gun ammo see what that gun looks like
pull it out I like this gun poof cool
umm I don't know what to do here
I can't go through here right okay so
I'll just go back the way I came through
the moment I think it's a good place to
end it if you go back to Allen's room
and save it okay I don't even know where
I am
oh you climb up to something back there
okay hold on it is a machine gun but I
still recommend ya single shotting it
like should I look in here anything or I
don't know if it'll let you I think
it'll still say check this
oh right okay so his room is to the
right I believe okay so I'm saving
thought there was a tape recorder in
here was there not no maybe that was in
the present
all right we're going a little further
sorry I mean it's also good cuz I would
be like oh I saw that did you see that
that was a foot no I didn't okay I just
made that up I thought I saw a foot so
she's like getting farther away
Oh goddamnit
that's unfortunate sorry I got like I
panicked
they're not like super powerful bullets
I just don't have a mr. health to like
[ __ ] around too much here yeah
cuz like wow that the bullets here did
you with you that door yep that's him
that's Athens
oh sorry that's Alan not Ethan that's
Ethan's home that's Alan he's not here
yet
[Music]
so what so back when you first saw that
first moulded on the what he puffed up
here no the first one in the hallway I
said you can climb yeah you already
so what am i doing I'm looking for bite
honey right Evelyn she's so far away am
I going the right way
[Applause]
oh sorry I really don't want to get hurt
so because I'm like spamming like I said
these bullets don't do as much damage so
they're not as valuable as gun rounds I
say per capita yeah I could really use
more gun bullets and guns okay good
[ __ ] for [ __ ] sake oh god I really
can't see okay oh sorry I like that I
keep apologizing I thought he I know I
thought he was alive so so I just kept
shooting him he's hard to tell if he's a
lot oh I almost missed you yeah if you
don't get the headshot it's tough to
tell when they just are actually better
just stumbling okay well I mean I'm
getting stuff down here
I need a crank
oh my god what their mapped it down wait
wait look at the the menu tells you the
controls for it
a bomb that could be detonated by remote
control press square to detonation
reload button
so is this to open up a door no don't do
that it's to kill a person okay
[ __ ] I hear it
[ __ ] oh god sorry
come on
Oh seeing the trailer for sold Valdo
Sicario - yet no Benicio del Toro goes
up to that dude and puts his finger like
on the trigger but then bounces it
really quick back and forth between the
trigger and the trigger guard yeah oh
that's super me and I don't know if that
would work in real life I guess it could
you'd have to be really good at guns
yeah
they kick more than you would think
I mean maybe more than I thought based
on obviously videogames and movies but
it still looks badass
oh no you tell he's pissed he's dead
like
sir there's nothing to it
I'm running out of bullets it's a bit
concerning okay so there's two doors
here this one check that one behind you
first well you have to get the most life
okay I have a knife now it's not a
pocket knife anymore it's a [ __ ] K
bar oh yeah which I would much rather
have that was a whit gross sound effect
wasn't it a strong acid that can
dissolve certain metals so I must have
to use this unlike a door is my guess or
something
maybe here I could try it okay touch it
sorry all right I'm down to 56 bullets
and two bombs
Mike Evie I'm not mad wait what did you
call me I don't and I want you to be my
mommy okay I'll be your mommy just just
come back with me right now okay
where are you Evie
it's kids scary it's [ __ ]
sweetie why are you precious so I came
from up I'm off from the beer maybe wait
can I leave
let's hope so did you find her
yes but she ran off she's making more
friends Allen those things are
everywhere
are you okay
[Music]
Oh No
[Music]
should I make one of those remote bombs
you have to make I'm already made like
that one up yeah when I stare Zeta
squared under way yeah
I didn't kill both of them
[Music]
starch should I just leave them yeah you
could uh although they're gonna have
another one you make it
I could really use
some bullies here you could start
dodging people now if you want well I
don't know you have corrosives use it on
the story here see it's in here
oh yeah there you go
another corrosive so your net Dean from
this room was very good so everybody go
now what am i doing
going back to Alan even what I write the
door there
Oh is everything that's right Kim you
need to go back to Alan I think or
follow Ebisu
I don't know if I'm allowed to go
through here
watching
but every bulb on this tier
if there's not even the same speed you
can get both of them
sorry I panicked there you go oh nice
the [ __ ] off
oh it's one of those prototype dudes I
get him yeah that last bullet went
straight through
okay he just like keeps crawling so it's
like yeah I mean like the only reason I
knew is just that last bullet didn't
connect with him because went straight
through got it
he stopped he ceased to be hip hop's
come on section is a little long for me
could like to hear that like woo for so
long
nobody resident remember at the end he
was the alarm music went off and one and
two and three so she's going to three I
think little guys are gonna come out of
here when I call this that's my guess
please don't fall out of the hole on the
way that would be super
emergency safety lockdown system has
been engaged
Cheers this section is long
where am i I'm unto and then I gotta
climb to three can also look through
this stuff
there's nowhere to save oh yeah you're
still in the past so I mean it's
auto-saving Alan Helen where the hell
are you
he did she's gonna like make me fight
him or some [ __ ]
this yeah go through there that to the
left in that Phoenix room
I could use a corrosive yeah is it worth
it
sure I mean we don't know I guess I
guess your guess is as good as mine eh I
assume that's worth it
but I shouldn't have
sorry oh my god I'm gonna die what
should I do
auto-fire we make one right [ __ ] I'm
like so hurt I can't walk yeah place it
down like here while you're running here
we go up now keep spreading
[Music]
nope
jeez I was really hurt as he got me
twice
[Music]
I did not do that very well I should
have ran the second I saw him I think
for whatever reason I was like now I can
get him well like so single-shot firing
is not always the rule it's just like it
helps same ammo there's gonna be another
one isn't there which way it's corrosive
door behind you
all right yeah there you go
I might have rimmel bond or something
I don't know what to do is this the
right way where is it
I didn't I heard it and I didn't I like
panicked is it in there hon go toward
the vomit first and maybe that all I
know is the one you already saw right
where is it
I'm hearing I can hear it I guess the
room you just went into but I wouldn't
use our mobile in close quarters
where is it have you gone in here before
yes all right
there's a back in the other room there's
like a crawl space you go through oh the
kitchen that just goes to the kitchen
out over on the other side of this
behind you I think
right there
what oh man that's the first way I got
into the kitchen oh okay gotcha um check
your watch
I guess there like I was supposed to
sorry is there any in here I don't think
you've been in here yet I have but I
couldn't get through that door Oh up
there there you go oh thank you I didn't
that's shut down because the alarm I
didn't see it thank you
[Music]
so I could go back to the first level
and get stuff no I was blocked off just
now got it okay Jesus I'm so sick of
hearing that noise yeah
me instinctively looking for Amma save
please let me say
there's no save so this is a rumor you
saw yeah her in the present like so this
this is really sneaky because it makes
me think it's a bad guy like that's
calculated [ __ ] it's Alan
how did you get here where's she's out
of control
without the treatments she's
deteriorating don't say that
she trusts him
that little [ __ ] you never trust okay
baby no baby
Ellen let me tell you that
[Music]
she's watches red yeah I just like that
little detail
nice Doc Martens TV
did I finish it I'm just oh I was gonna
say I'm just glad that the alarm has
gone it's a really long section so now
I'm infected is that what I learned I
guess that's how you're infected when
Ethan sees you Baker house this is the
same
don't watch it yet
I already I think you get back out
whatever Blodgett sorry all right
it's 39 seconds long
oh nevermind I see other
you were right I did lie to you
I shouldn't have all I can say is if you
get this
stay away forget that you ever knew me
okay so that was the video from the very
beginning of the game first thing you
see all right there should be a same
thing in here I'm pretty positive
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah she loved me Carosa so you
can't even get through that
that's a few sir
what it might be a fused or maybe have
to go back and I'll try to start first I
mean I definitely can't do it sorry
Oh see you like yourself Loretta
have a bomb oh wait that's no that hurt
me No
[ __ ] little creep wait okay what am i
doing
did I die okay okay
I am I playing
[Music]
yeah there's a safe hooray
[Applause]
that counts mm-hmm good job
that was weird it's very different than
the rest of the game so far it's kind of
like a different game a bit it's not as
scary as the house the house is just
like somehow very scary to me whereas
the boat wasn't but relatable it's also
like I can imagine [ __ ] going down at a
house as opposed to a tanker it was an
interesting chapter I don't know how
much I learned besides obviously this
little girl is very much involved also
Evy is involved with like biological
weapons and that Evy kind of is one hmm
and they're transporting her to South
America don't know what the company is
but you're trying to transport her to
South America and then apparently that
happened somewhere in the Gulf and you
wash up in Louisiana got it no you
killed your dad we can't be a family we
were never a family we will never be a
family yeah yay yeah so you and Allen
they said in the case of an accident or
like Border Patrol's or killers no well
no in the case may accident kill her but
you seemed to be too attached there to
kill her but they also said you have to
act as her parents if something goes
wrong you don't know who her real
parents are you don't know what she is
you just know that you and Allen were
her quasi a rental figures go up so
how's your perception of the game
changed so far I mean it's still really
good it's still high I want to know more
what's going on I'm hoping that it
doesn't become this type of thing where
it's like in all the Resident Evil's
it's always like what's going on here
and then you say that 10 more times and
you never really learn what's going on
here I'm hoping that it'll actually give
me
some kind of actual closure something
that feels genuine like I understood
what happened so you have any idea that
this tanker section was gonna happen no
yeah that's like the thing that the
marketing hit and I'm surprised that
didn't get spoiled for you because it's
not having seen it I didn't ask I knew
nothing about the boat I knew nothing
about it's more industrial bioterrorism
stuff than the older games now yeah I
knew nothing this whole this whole
section is new to me I have no idea
what's going on but more for the next
episode yep
I started looking I started perusing a
bit but I'm gonna stop
I know sorry I'm his doctor so that's it
for this year it's been wonderful year
of knievel this will go up on Christmas
is on Monday the 25th so like that 29 29
sounds right
yeah next week I think we'll be able to
record yeah I should come back in
January so she be able to record so
sweet more then thank you hanging out to
us 2017 everybody it's been a good
Knievel year yeah we're almost done with
7 Mary Knievel miss on that note
happy 2017 happy new resonable says fear
how